house cameras - Peter back and today I'm
here way and I'm sick she's sick I don't
have any friends we're gonna play the
drunken wrestlers it's been suggested by
you bros so it better be game how to
play the goal is before his opponent to
lose balance or inflict critical damage
I never played this game before it by
the way so if I win which I will it's
because she sucks why don't we play oh
there we go so you don't lose balance
dota - don't touch my nips oh no no I'll
choke you [ __ ] you want me you want me
cuz you try to give me I'm gonna scratch
your face Joe you're damaging me more
than I'm damaging you
oh come on oh good okay you very seen
yourself no what is he doing gonna get
you kick her no guys don't do that no no
no no yes hug each other ah what what
was it one draw does that mean it means
equal but you're accusing my feet right
now second guy win
[Music]
now you don't do that when you're trying
Oh God
come here come i getcha I'm gonna getcha
attack don't dance
don't what so you go you lean forward
with the former Abby and wheeling
backwards you want me to tear your
choice of apart oh oh oh oh oh
today I don't care about anybody does
that mean how do you win I'm gonna tear
your ass apart again nipple twist bud
I'm gonna hurt you Oh what draws out you
are into people don't challenge joke
don't what are you doing right now
wait yeah why why you fell I destroyed
you everything
you see I'm gonna step on you're gonna
cry
how do you like my attack I'm tired
walking yo nice attack bro yeah I did it
what draw bulls crapper I'm sorry you're
fun
yeah my way but you have five points
it's a Knightly way but okay last one
this is not fair okay I'm kind of a
romantic about dying
what does that even mean
stop hurting me I'm backing up I'm
begging it
back it up back it up back it up yeah
yes
don't you mean it no good way to rub it
in my face
Oh God come on I'm trying so hard
shut up shut your damn them alright a
pulse is deeper dad don't ever by vanish
mister did you piss huh don't waste my
time dawg thank God
that's what she said okay how about we
both attack each other at three one two
three I won fair and square and then I'm
gonna walk over here and sleep oh yeah
those drunken wrestlers I'm pretty best
at it you practice days oh don't leave
like right now if you like drunk
wrestling